on the periphery of the solar system
there is a little world Bound by toxic
eyes lurking amid the great abyss of
space
a Giant Shadow covering the stars from
sight is unmovable over its rugged
Horizon
and the dim sun slowly traverses the sky
the sun rays here are not able to
dissipate the semi-darkness of the
Frozen plain wrinkled with bottomless
crevices is perpetually shrouded in
this is Pluto a lifeless Kingdom of rock
and dice covered by Perpetual shadow
let's find out more about it
[Music]
Pluto is about 40 astronomical units
away from the Sun
and is a dark and indistinguishable
object
this distant Celestial body follows a
rather elongated orbit around the center
of the solar system completing it every
248 Earth years
we know that Pluto's radius is
1188 kilometers which means that it is
noticeably inferior in size not only to
all the planets of the solar system but
also to some of their satellites
including the Moon
at the same time observations of the
celestial body's proper motion made it
possible to calculate its mass with a
high degree of accuracy
turned out to be small
only 1.3 times 10 to the power of 22
kilograms or 18 of the lunar Mass
it is easy to see that Pluto is much
more similar to small celestial bodies
such as aerys Ceres or sadna in terms of
its characteristics this is the reason
why it topped the list of dwarf planets
in 2006.
due to its long and elongated trajectory
Pluto has a long orbital cycle
only in 1989 did the planetoid first
pass its orbit perihelion since its
Discovery approaching the Sun as close
as 29.7 astronomical units
since then this distance has been
continuously increasing and will reach
its greatest value in the year 2113. by
that time the dwarf planets will be near
its aphelion which is 49.3 astronomical
units away from the center of our system
thus Pluto is a very distant and dim
space object
that is the reason why it cannot be seen
from Earth with the naked eye and even
in images from the Hubble Space
Telescope the dwarf planet looks like a
murky Brown disc without any surface
details
of course in such conditions it is
almost impossible to study the celestial
body properly
to solve this problem the New Horizons
unmanned orbital station was sent to
Pluto in 2006.
it took a long nine and a half years to
reach his destination on its way it
beamed back to us detailed images of
Jupiter it wasn't until 2015 that the
spacecraft finally reached the main
object of its Mission as it flew past
Pluto the station made about 400
observations collecting more than six
gigabytes of information and it took
more than a year to transmit this large
amount of data to Earth
unfortunately the probe's trajectory did
not allow photographing the entire
surface of the dwarf planet the fact is
that New Horizons did not enter into an
orbit around Pluto but circled round
Pluto in order to be able to explore
other space objects
before moving on to the celestial bodies
terrain features we need to understand
its internal structure
according to the currently accepted
model Pluto has a massive core with a
diameter of about 1 700 kilometers
consisting of a mixture of various forms
of water ice and rocks in its Center it
is surrounded by 300 kilometer ice
mantle there are probably tectonic
processes running in the mantle and in
the moment they're quite understudied
the mantle in its turn is covered by a
crust which is a mixture of crystallized
Gases such as nitrogen methane and
carbon monoxide
According to some assumptions Pluto's
core May generate enough heat to melt
some of the icy mantle in this case deep
beneath the surface of the planetoid
there should hide a very salty and toxic
ocean containing large amounts of
dissolved ammonia as for the surface
temperature of the dwarf planet it is
very low and is not over 60 Kelvin or
213 degrees Celsius below zero
our journey around Pluto will start at
the most outstanding and well studied
feature of its relief tombow Reggio
this vast area is located in the
equatorial zone of the planetoid and is
shaped like a hard sketch this
resemblance earned the region its
informal nickname the heart its size
reaches 2 300 kilometers which means
that the plane occupies about a quarter
of the celestial body's entire area
tombow reggio's surface is not
homogeneous thus there is a smooth and
Light plane in its western part known as
Sputnik planisha whose diameter measures
1492 kilometers an elevation map will
reveal this region to be a vast lowland
area
it is covered with a thick layer of
nitrogen ice as well as carbon monoxide
and solid methane these substances have
a light coloring which makes some parts
of the plane reflect up to 90 percent
with the light falling on them
there are also virtually no craters
which means that the region is very
young in geological terms
according to the main hypothesis
Sputnik lenisha formed about a hundred
million years ago when Pluto experienced
a collision with a large Celestial body
as a result a huge impact crater
appeared it was filled with contents of
the hypothetical inner ocean of the
dwarf planet which rapidly froze there
some typical features of the relief of
the plane can serve as evidence of this
for example there are quite a number of
smooth surface areas on it ranging from
20 to 30 kilometers in size with hills
and depressions concentrated on the
borders between them this kind of
structure resembles convection cells
which appear in any fluid heated From
Below
this may serve as an indirect
confirmation of the hypothesis of
Pluto's warm interior
tombow Reggio is surrounded by
comparatively high mountain ridges
thus Hillary Monty's lying to the west
from sputnikplanetia reach three and a
half kilometers in height townsing
Montes are located in the southern part
of the heart
some of them Tower as high as over six
kilometers above the dwarf planet's
average surface level which makes this
Ridge the tallest one found on Pluto
remarkably these rocks are likely to be
made up mostly of Water Ice
and in temperatures as low as here on
Pluto water ice is a solid as rock
moving a little further south we can see
a deep Basin surrounded by Massive
motorlayered Ridges of ice and rock it
is assumed that it may be the vent of an
ancient cryo volcano and the rock around
it is its numerous Frozen eruptions
their chemical composition is of great
interest to science because once it is
known the peculiarities of Pluto's inner
makeup may be studied the eastern part
of tombau Reggio is darker in addition
its surface is pockmarked with a great
number of craters which means that this
region is by far Elder than Sputnik
planisha moving further east along the
Equator we will see a chain of dark
spots hundreds of kilometers in diameter
these objects are called maculars and
are named after dark deities of various
cultures for example one of them is
named balrog
together they form a giant structure
called the brass knuckles encompassing
the celestial body along the Equator the
maculas are separated by high mountain
ranges and their surface is cut by Deep
crevices reaching hundreds of kilometers
in length Cthulhu macula stretches to
the west from tombau Reggio it is the
largest dark spot on Pluto measuring
almost 3 000 kilometers its surface
reflects not more than 30 percent of the
light shed on it which is a stark
contrast with a bright and light
sputnikplanetia close by
there is still no reliable information
about what maculars are it is assumed
that their dark color is due to a high
content of thurlins combined with a
relatively large concentration of impact
craters this indicates that maculas are
remarkably old it is also known that the
surface of Cthulhu macula is
heterogeneous thus its relief in the
western part is undulating
the central part is a smooth plane and
the eastern part is covered with
mountains and craters
foreign
spot of Cthulhu macula behind us let's
head north here lies Lowell Reggio the
vast Valley surrounding Pluto's North
Pole
surprisingly it is this place that is
currently the most illuminated part of
the celestial body's surface
the point is that Pluto's axis of
rotation has a very large tilt with
respect to the plane of its orbit so in
its movement it found itself facing the
sun with its North Pole it is assumed
that is for this reason that the density
of Pluto's atmosphere has tripled over
the past 30 years despite the growing
distance from the Sun
it is likely that the sun's Rays
evaporate nitrogen ice settle to the
pole which goes into the dwarf planet's
atmosphere
in its orbital motion Pluto has a number
of peculiarities compared to the planets
of the solar system in addition to the
fact that its orbit has a noticeable
tilt to the ecliptic plane the planetoid
itself constantly performs cyclic
oscillations near a certain point
this is due to the presence of a large
satellite gravitationally affecting the
dwarf planet it is called Sharon and its
mass is 1.52 times 10 to the power of 21
kilograms
which is more than 11 percent the mass
of Pluto itself
as a consequence both celestial bodies
orbit a common Mass center between them
they're tidally locked to each other so
they face each other with the same sides
at all times
are like Pluto's the surface of its
satellite is noticeably darker and shows
an abundance of water ice which is mixed
with methane and nitrogen only in some
regions
in addition to Sharon there are several
other satellites but all of them are
much smaller and irregular in shape
Nixon Hydra discovered in 2005 measure
several tens of kilometers and kerberus
and sticks which were discovered later
are not over 16 kilometers in diameter
all of these celestial bodies consist
mainly of water ice and were probably
captured by Pluto's Gravity from the
Kuiper belt
unfortunately a significant part of
Sharon was not caught in the field of
view of the New Horizons probe's cameras
but many curious terrain features can be
found on the visible surface of the
celestial body
for example to the south of the Equator
that lies a vast region called Vulcan
plenum its area is not known precisely
but it is not less than 400 000 square
kilometers which is comparable with the
size of an average European country
here the highest Summit of Sharon can be
found kubrik Mars its diameter measures
around 40 kilometers and according to
some estimates its height reaches 4000
meters in addition the mountain is
surrounded by a wide circular moat as it
were up to two kilometers deep According
to some assumptions Kubrick mons May in
fact be a cryo volcano in this case it
is very likely that their air around it
has sunk under its own weight due to the
amping of the underground reservoir to
the north stretches the vast Oz Terror
the surface of which is bookmarked with
many craters it is separated from Vulcan
plenum by a system of giant Ledges and
crevices with a total height of about a
kilometer the largest of them is
Serenity kasma which is 200 kilometers
long with a width varying from 40 to 50
kilometers it can be as deep as seven
kilometers and it is difficult to
explore its bottom because because of
the thick Shadows cast by the steep
slopes
further north yet near the very pole
there is the giant Mordor macular its
diameter reaches 475 kilometers and its
origin is still debatable according to
the dominant hypothesis today nitrogen
and methane floating from Pluto's
atmosphere were trapped by Sharon's
gravity and so settled at its poles
after exposure to ultraviolet radiation
they turned into tholins and gradually
concentrated in the ice of the celestial
body this assumption needs verification
which will be an object of future
missions
Sharon largely remains a mystery to us
because its research is only just
starting
although the Pluto Sharon system is
undoubtedly one of the most interesting
structures in the solar system it is
still understudied unfortunately the New
Horizons probe left its environs long
ago and the celestial bodies themselves
are rapidly moving away from us taking
their secrets along
at the moment the probe is more than 50
astronomical units away from the Earth
and from time to time beams back to us
some extremely important data
by about 2030 all of its systems will
eventually fail and the probe will be
left all alone in the chilling recesses
of space
[Music]
dear friends we're currently not
uploading new videos on our Channel as
often as we'd prefer
their production requires more and more
time and duffet because we want to
improve and make worthy videos of the
highest quality your support is the main
motivation that helps the channel to
move forward so we will always
appreciate it when you acknowledge our
effort with likes new exciting videos
will come out sooner with you looking
forward to it
let's keep in touch